[Music]
bachelor nation i'm lauren zima we
literally just watched the season finale
part two it's really all done of Hannah
Browns unbelievable season of The
Bachelorette and oh my god we got Jed
proposing to Hannah with a guitar and a
song oh god we got Hannah and Jed
turns out they broke up they're not
together we got Tyler C and Hannah going
out for drinks
this episode was unbelievable we're
about to talk it through grab your
glasses it's time for roses and rose
a-and you guys I am joined by our
wonderful Entertainment Tonight online
writer Jenn Drysdale who covers the
Bachelorette Shearer's furor let's take
a drink we need a drink
we just closed Jen's laptop she just
finished covering the episode and you
guys we want your comments we want your
questions send them through we will get
them here on our iPad and while you're
starting to comment and you we're gonna
go through the whole episode I just want
to give a shout out because Jen Jen made
this cake
I mean well cover up just in case I
acquired this cake its bleeped out she
she made a cake for Peter and Hannah do
you know what in the windmill not once
not twice the four times
uh-huh that's how we celebrate here we
also have of course an absolutely
massive bottle of wine that's what we
needed for tonight for this
unforgettable finale and we have burgers
in price because we know how this nights
gonna go oh yeah yeah all right we have
everything we need let's start talking
about it I just want to drink for every
oh my god moment so again let's just
just here we go here we go okay play
along and always drink responsibly first
of all we get where we left off yes
on Monday night Hannah decides to dump
our respectful King Taylor Cameron oh oh
obsessed fan girl do you think Hannah
and Tyler will make it well we're gonna
get to it
dumps Tyler in favor of Jed how much did
your heart drop when you saw Tyler say
this isn't it okay this was the most
devastating moment maybe of my entire
life
oh wow I have never loved a man I never
knew more than Tyler Cameron never loved
a man I never knew more yes
so Tyler Cameron as I have been calling
him Tyler see proud to be scandal-free
yep has literally done no wrong this no
wrong and I think he continued to do no
wrong with this being dumped moment his
proposal to Hannah was unbelievable i
transcribed him fully on twitter and
i'll see you guys jen has been doing a
live blog of the finale it's up on our
website for every single moment easy
online calm and his proposal was amazing
the way he left after she broke up with
him he said I wish you and Jed the best
Tyler did no wrong but they were no more
and obsessed fangirl let's get right to
your question do you think Hannah and
Tyler will make it I mean guys spoiler
alert I guess but if you're here we're
literally talking only about the finale
Hannah and Tyler at the end of the
finale decided they're gonna go on a
drink together after seeing her dump him
after seeing the way he took it after
hearing that they both still had
feelings for each other do you think
they will make it
what does make it mean do you think that
they will stay together I think they
will explore a relationship and we will
see do they have more going for them
because they didn't get engaged maybe
less pressure maybe I don't know we'll
see I have to be a hundred percent
honest about my feelings on the two of
them on stage together it felt awkward I
don't know if that was because it's live
TV and adorable Tyler we know he gets a
little nervous yeah it's totally swore
by the way they had to bleep him out
thank you for that live TV delay but it
certainly wasn't a we are boyfriend and
girlfriend known it was they were gonna
grab a drink and you know what you're
still grabbing a drink
oh-ho what do you guys think do you
think Hannah and Tyler will make it does
making it mean getting engaged do you
want them to get engaged Tyler said he
was ready to propose to Hannah Hannah
said she saw it feelings for Tyler
I must admit I don't think this
guarantees a rock on her finger let's
listen to a bit of the Hannah Tyler
reconciliation moment you're incredible
guy and I'm a single girl
[Applause]
yeah I don't know I just thought maybe
we could go her drink and just hang it I
would love to just tell me what I'm not
let's listen to the words again it's
live TV maybe they were uncomfortable I
mean she's asking the man she dumped out
again alive to you she said go for a
drink and quote just hang out yeah I
don't know it's tough for Tyler it
really is right because what's he going
to do say no he can't say no I have to
use a respectful King he has a
reputation to uphold let us know if you
guys think that Tyler was backed into a
corner on this one not that Hannah's a
bad corner to be backed into she's
wonderful I know you love she looked
great she looked amazing but I will say
I do think he could have it makes me
think he still has some feelings for her
because I do think he could have said
Hannah I adore you and you broke up with
me for another guy and it's been months
and I've kind of put those feelings away
but then again she was just saying let's
get a drink and a half and hang out yeah
call it a date yeah
she didn't it was Chris Harrison he's
had to bring that up well he said we
ship it but that doesn't mean it is it
just means we're shipping it yeah and
you guys let me know what you think does
this bother you because at this point
did you want Tyler C to be bachelor I
tweeted right after he dumped him don't
know if it's too soon Tyler Seifer
Bachelor ha ha ha great it's not easy
alright more of your comments coming in
Kelly gamble says I don't think Tyler
deserves to be a back-up plan and look I
do want to say like some people were
asking us yesterday will Hannah pull a
Jason mesnick's yeah not the same
situation Hanna didn't have all the
information with Jed she didn't
knowingly pick Jed exactly as he was she
was sorted she was lied to and so I
don't think it's on that same level but
I see your point Kelly
well I'll er a backup Lee no he's much
more well I think that's why it's tough
for Tyler because Hanna didn't say well
actually my feelings for you are
stronger than they ever were for dead
she had a devastating event happen with
Jed and now she's left with Tyler or no
one pretty much Hanna has come away from
the finale winning 100
oh yeah also I will say I think if Tyler
isn't the bachelor that certainly clears
the way for Peter I don't know about
Mike I know mike is still allegedly in
the conversation but you guys I asked
Mike at the men tell all have you had
conversations with producers about
potentially being the bachelor and he
said no and like look anything can
happen
Colton became the bachelor after going
on bachelor in paradise we've got a lot
of time ahead but I would imagine that
those conversations would have been
happened well I believe they've
definitely happened with Peter because
they brought his entire family it's
allowed to that job yes the lobster I
can get behind Peters parents I mean a
lot of face touching we both went right
in for it all right um you guys are
saying Rebecca says the wine glass is in
Moot ash see is that actually crossing
so how big is that wine glass it's huge
Barry had to order it on the Internet
here's what I love about it it can serve
as a wine glass if you want to pour the
wine into it or you put a little ice in
it that's a wine bottle holder it's a
chiller yeah multi-purpose you know to
things like Jen and Tyler okay um more
comments from you guys Allie saying what
do you think of Jed's apology to Hanna
elphaba what a cool names saying I got
to give props to Jed who unlike Luke at
least admitted he was wrong let's talk
about that the other major moment of the
night Jed coming out and facing Hannah
well one of many major moments I went
into this saying Jed has to own
everything yeah he has to apologize
multiple days he has to say he was wrong
oh yeah and I agree he did way better
than Luke and you guys I know people
came for the way that Luke was treated
and name-calling is never okay but if
Luke had owned things had apologized
more I think we would have all rallied
around him I will say tonight Jed did
everything he could do all he could do
was own it and apologize over and over
he did and that's what he did he did it
with Hanna their one-on-one conversation
he did it when he came out and talked to
the audience and Chris do I love him
no I will admit I don't think that in
their one-on-one conversation and let's
just pull up that footage and show some
of Jed and Hanna talking in that
additional moment that we got not the
live on stage but when he came and first
talked to her I don't think that Jed we
being 100% honest with Hannah here and
that bothered me I mean he said tonight
on the live portion he said look I've
reflected even more and I really wasn't
as he put it my best self but I was
frustrated with him here in this moment
because I don't think he was even
telling her everything here she was Matt
you didn't tell me everything in the
beginning and even here the stuff he was
saying was not adding up to me Hannah
brought up a story that Entertainment
Tonight broke by the way that you and I
worked on Jed's
acts who I interviewed Haley Stephens
sent us text messages between the two of
them where he said I love you to her
allegedly as he was getting on the plane
to go film the show yeah well Hannah
brought that up with Jed on the episode
tonight the text that we first published
for you guys said she'd seen them asked
him about it let's listen to Jed's
response to Hannah about his alleged I
love you
Jed claims that he was drunk here's the
tip we're sitting there on this
extravagant trip I've been drinking I'm
not gonna make that an excuse but I had
them and I told her that I loved her so
it would seem that Jed's story here is
that he was maybe drunk alone okay he
says he was drunk but then he later
admits that he told her I love you three
or four more times
what suggestions we have a lot of
questions what by the way you guys I'm
gonna go ahead and tell you we do plan
to speak to Haley Stephens again so we
will bring that to you because Haley
Jed's ex-girlfriend where this whole
story came from that allegedly Jed went
on the show well now I don't even know
if I have to say alleged anymore it's
pretty much confirmed it went on the
show having just said I love you to her
went on the show for his career well
she's now seen how he owned up to it all
tonight or you know maybe lies that she
might have feel like he had told we are
going to address that with her so Jed
says that he was drunk but that that
text that we have seems pretty coherent
he's telling her meditate be positive I
love you and he's telling her this as he
gets on the plane
yes this was a bit of a revelation
Hannah also confronted Jed not just
about Haley but about apparently having
women to hang over in his house in
Nashville after they were engaged take a
look at this moment I have text messages
from other girls from the night after I
was in Nashville these two girls were in
your apartment yeah we didn't even know
who they were
oh you Thurman Poole that's a no my god
moment let's drink for that let's drink
for that I love how he leaned over you
threw them in the pool we did did mom
Wanda says what is the four for four
from the text I don't know Hannah
brought it up tonight
we asked Haley we asked Haley and she I
don't think Haley no we don't know I
think it's a dead thing maybe he was
intoxicated from the four four four I
don't know either way it seems to have
come become clear that Jed told Haley I
love you multiple times but in that
conversation with Hannah he's
frustrating me for so many reasons he's
telling her I was drunk when I said I
love you even though I said several
times he's telling her well yeah we went
on the trip together me in this girl but
it's cuz I got the cabin for free oh my
god
I guess the dog food jingle is not
paying that well oh he's saying oh yes
we went on a trip together but it's
because her parents bought it for me for
my birthday after she threw me a
surprise party he was literally arguing
that she wasn't his girlfriend but also
admitting that she threw him a surprise
party and that her parents got him a
gift I'm sorry but now you're now you're
claiming that her whole family are kind
of a bunch of stalkers well my favorite
part of this was when he opened up about
he how she casually met his family oh
yes they happen to be somewhere and then
it finally clicked for Hannah oh wait
this is why your hometown date was so
incredibly awkward I adored not adored
it felt satisfied
to hear Hannah have the same process
that we've all been having but she's
like now your hometown with your family
makes sense now I see why they were so
skeptical because that's what we've all
been thinking as we've been watching
everything Jed says and does and
everything with his family appeared
different to us we were looking at it
through a different lens and you know
Hannah didn't know I thought that Hannah
handled the whole conversation with Jed
so well let's take a listen to the
moment where she talks about what she
said yes to with Jed when they got
engaged this
doesn't mean the same thing that's not
what I suggest you
[Applause]
she took off the ring oh my god by the
way the audience the live studio
audience was shouting take the ring off
haha even in that moment and let me know
what you guys think but I feel that if
in that moment Jed in that conversation
if he had really owned up to everything
really apologized Jed and Hanna might
have had a chance there but I think
Hanna's really smart and she knew you're
really not giving me the whole story
here and the girls in the pool in the
Nashville house that's something we
didn't know about but that was another
nail in the coffin
you're really not living the lifestyle
of an engaged person you're really not
understanding this and taking it serious
no no and as she pointed out this isn't
about you Jed it's us and you're past
that you weren't clear to me about I
think she said is now your present and
our future
she was so why he came ready
she came ready not just tonight but back
at that conversation yes so proud of
Hanna that was fascinating stuff to find
out fascinating to learn I mean some
things we learned tonight we could do a
whole list as we've put all the pieces
of the puzzle together not the loopy
puzzle never forget that but found out
that Jed first told Hannah about the
girlfriend yeah a night or two after
they got engaged right so he didn't even
tell her in the fantasy suites
beforehand as Jed said he was afraid to
lose her well you really kind of make
sure it made sure he didn't he didn't
tell her the whole story she found out
about the story breaking the night
before it happened and even then she
said he didn't really tell her the whole
story I mean drink for every time that
Jed seemingly didn't tell her the whole
story please do it was a lot okay more
comments from you guys
Catherine B says I really want to know
Haley's reaction to Jed throwing her
under the bus Catherine we're gonna get
that for you taemin tonight stay tuned
follow us on social we will have Haley's
report for you
Sharla B says best relationship to come
out of the franchise's Demi Lovato and
Hannah brown yes they hung out last
night after the finale and just posted a
pic on Instagram and remember Demi said
she's into Mike so I don't know if we
can have Mike for bachelor because Demi
Lovato and Mike my date I was hoping
that might be the happy end think that
we got oh my god if they'd come out on
this end
Chris Harrison in the middle Mike and
Hanna on one couch and Tyler Mike and
Debbie on one couch Tyler hand on the
other foot I ship yes Robin says
king-size wine glass for King Tyler yes
Robin respectful King Tyler I just did a
little ASMR an accident sorry I love
those videos Sydney says our Tyler and
Jed friends how does this work
Sydney that is such a good question we
have seen Tyler show Jed some love on
social media throughout the season but I
don't know how much love has been shown
since it came out that Jed was listen
Tyler admitted I thought you were in
good hands that's what he told Hanna
they were sitting in that hot seat so
clearly he doesn't think judge sands are
that great I will say when we were at
men tell all covering that you know the
other guys and obviously Tyler wasn't at
men tell all but the other guys did get
in Jen's corner a little bit I said you
know like we don't think he's a bad guy
and tonight after Jed's apology Hanna
was very gracious with Jed she said I
think you have the potential to be a
good guy you got to make that happen now
I think she handled that perfectly a lot
of people came at Hanna for how she was
with Luke but again I think Jed on
things more than Luke and so he got a
little more grace from Hanna mm-hmm by
the way cheers to hopefully never saying
the word clarity again expand even
tonight even that last episode to tell
you guys we got clarity probably 10
times so much clarity and I have none of
it I know I like my clip my clarity just
in my Rose a just a light very clear
rose and that's all I want okay more
from you guys Ava Green says I wish dad
would have sang his apology with his
guitar do you I do I really do I was
over that proposal but if he had sang
his guitar that's the one moment I could
have done with in this finale and it
gave me a lot Chris Harrison said the
proposal was going to be cringe-worthy
let's take a look at Jed proposing to
Hanna in part by singing her an original
[Music]
and those times you wish you knew
who's on the other side Jen just pointed
out was the song original I mean I think
I think they would have had to give some
credit or place some as awkward as a
silence in the room is that's how
awkward it was when Jen played that song
wasn't did she I don't know I I
screenshot and I love all right I felt
she I felt she leaned into it at first I
think she was like what is this really
happening and then she's like okay all
season long you're right she did
love the jet and the guitar thing let me
know what you guys think but I've kind
of been saying all season just for me I
don't get down with a dude playing the
guitar next to me it I find it awkward
this certainly was awkward you're
proposing I don't know
you know Jed has said over and over
again that he went on the show he said
over it over again tonight you know he
kind of went on the show for his career
and he didn't think he'd really fall in
love and fall in love this fast he
didn't really get it I would be
fascinated to know if Jed had watched
bachelor shows before like how much that
holds up and if his family did I think
he certainly watched Jillian Harris's
season where her own her own musician
made it to top four and that's where he
got the idea
hey-oh Nicole said loved watching Hannah
grow through the show she is badass I
agree and I applauded everything about
the way she handled tonight let us know
if you guys thought Hannah should have
handled ever anything differently um
Jenn at one point kind of said he still
felt for Hannah during the live portion
let's take a listen to Jed kind of sort
of maybe trying to get back together
with Ian Alison but my life for you I
don't think they won't ever leave me
it's just something that is there to
stay so you're still in love with this
woman no I always will be
I'm not trying to punish you or but my
feelings have changed was he trying to
get back together with her I think he
was trying to open that door and see
where she was but clearly that door is
closed
yeah when is the crack he putting a
guitar through at first he slammed it
right the guitar was blended into many
pieces yes yeah I mean I think you're
right he was he was testing the waters
but I would imagine he knew what the
answer would be and they had not spoken
seemingly since they broke up over the
phone I would love to know when that was
how many two been Hannah and Tyler had
not seen each other apparently since
Greece but yeah so Jed said he would
always be in love with Hannah which is
you know yet another wild thing for Jed
to say considering he said I love you to
Haley
so how would Hannah have felt knowing
that her fiance would always be in love
with someone else
listen Jeff love is very confusing and I
I assume will write a lot of songs about
it to be continued
amanda says Jed wants to release all
these songs from the show on iTunes
that's right and you're gonna drink for
not buying them we're not gonna buy them
sorry
I didn't think the dog food jingle was
bad no he had a lovely voice for ads yes
and great you know and a catchy tune for
ads I think yeah lean into that lean
into that yes
Larissa's II he had to promote his music
even as proposing one last plug yeah as
you said he could have brought the
guitar out tonight I mean that would
have been so literally tone-deaf how do
you Tod he apologized with the guitar
would Hanna consider getting back with
him she loves that guitar you're right
that he had a loves it oh my god but god
I don't think so Hannah's too smart for
it ana points out jed never cried or
showed hardly any emotion it was really
fascinating I always love when they
break the fourth wall a little bit when
during that Jed and Hannah conversation
the camera people rushed in
and Hannah had gone outside they all
rushed back in to keep filming and Jed
at one point said I don't want to cry on
camera yeah
and Hannah said why not I do think that
that might lend itself you know to this
train of thought that Jed just was
worried about how he would appear I
think if we've learned anything from
this season it's that Jed Wyatt wants a
career in music and that is his endgame
that is his number one goal his number
one priority and that's it yeah as Harry
B says it's har RI that's great you go
on vacation and tell someone you love
you're not dating yeah a trip with
someone a solo trip with someone Jed
that's pretty significant I saw those
coconuts
yuh-huhhh and again it was right before
he went on the show what else
Kalyn says did Jett actually tell his
friends he won instead of getting
engaged
Hannah pointed that out to him she said
that you were telling all your friends
after we got together you won the show
Jed didn't deny it
he didn't he didn't deny it and it's not
the best wording is it Holly says were
you nervous Hannah might take Jed back I
was not I felt that she was so closed
off to him her body language her tone
she wasn't crying she wasn't emotional
about it anymore and I think once you've
turned that corner of not even being
upset over c1 the walls up well we
interviewed her at at mental and
honestly it was seeing her there and
going through those interviews having to
answer the tough questions where we hint
at does your heart get broken girlfriend
didn't give anything up and that's when
I knew okay
either way this ends Hannah's over it
she's moved on it's not raw yeah mm-hmm
so Jed and Hannah see each other again
she confronts him I also want to
oh sorry ignore me no no we don't have
that um I just really admired everything
about what Hannah said about the love
that she deserves and again on stage she
said this is not the love I do
deserve I deserved honesty she'd been
consistent on that from the start that's
what she wanted she said she would be
fine being single then have a
relationship like that
cheers to Hannah for all season long
just being an absolute Queen on our TV
screens here's the Hannah hmm his Hannah
your favorite box or whatever I think he
might be mine she she said in this
finale multiple times how she's noticed
the growth within herself yes and I
noticed it too and I've never seen
growth like that in any bachelor
franchise lead in the history of the
entire franchise never I was looking
back at some of our first interviews
including including back when I
interviewed Hannah for the women's hell
yeah Holden's season and she set and I
asked her then because there were rumors
you know she's a potential Bachelorette
contender and I said would you be open
to it she said yes I believe in this
process and she said I want to be a
hundred percent genuine she said I want
to peel back the layers of myself and
learn and grow even more and I just want
to cheers to Hannah because I think she
did all that she said consistent on
message she did it all she did her
jennifer saying tyler didn't look too
happy when she asked him out I would be
absolutely fascinated to know if Tyler
had been told by producers or anyone
that that could potentially happen on I
hope he was told I really I hope he was
okay but does that ruin the moment the
the romance the romance of it no I would
I would really appreciate if all of this
was set up ahead of time if he knew
should you want to know that your live
moments are set up yes I want to know I
don't want any awkwardness she's gone
through enough awkwardness I don't need
any more from Tyler see I want to know
that he knew this was coming that he was
into it that he said okay I'm into it
I'm gonna tell her that I'm into it and
I'm gonna say it on live TV and here we
go and there we go we're going on a date
that's what I wanted from this I mean he
definitely seemed a little nervous like
we said he accidentally dropped he think
there was I think was the live aspect of
it but so by the way you know Luke peek
coming up a little bit again Shelby ray
says not a fan of loopy but at least he
was there for the right reasons
I appreciated Hanna explaining that
that's why she felt so strongly about
Luke
the beginning made sense jed certainly
wasn't also good that hannah said what
we were all thinking calling jet out on
the fact that on night one yeah that guy
scott said he got caught in having a
girlfriend and she was like Jed didn't
that make you think you should say
something you should say something I
have to be honest I did not buy Jed's
reasoning of just being afraid of losing
Hanna I didn't and I would love to
interview him and I would love to talk
to him about it and I don't cover from a
place of malice or anger with Jed but I
do think that he was just caught in a
lie that he kept building upon the lie
of it as he has said he was ultimately
there for his career if he had told her
in the fantasy suites or even like the
night after they got engaged about the
girlfriend do you think they'd still be
together now it depends what he would
told her about the girlfriend well I
mean if he told her the whole truth no
really no I'm saying that would've been
a quick turnaround it was already a
pretty quick she said Scott home before
they even took the cast photo yeah he
was before they took the cast photos
like out of here oh man more comments
from you guys Rebekah says are you going
to interview Tyler we're certainly going
to try we have to make sure that we you
know that these people are all under
contracts we got to try to get them for
interviews we're working on it
because Cheers Center van Tyler
responsible uh Emily Dawson do you think
that things will be like this from now
on we're bachelors and bachelorettes
will not get engaged by the end well
Hannah did get engaged
she did she did she's done did she don't
did and then she don't she gone yeah he
gone and that's okay
um we are going to wrap up here you guys
this has been so unbelievable I mean
again our takeaway moments here Hannah
chose Jed yes
Jed chose to propose with a guitar in a
song yes then he chose to not tell
Hannah the full truth about his
situation with his ex-girlfriend and he
also seemingly chose to lied to her
about the realities of his desires and
going on the show and his intended path
then she chose to break up with Jed and
she chose to ask Tyler for drinks so
let's finish the very last of our Rose a
we just have drops lap we're like Hannah
and Tyler out on a drink together haha
and Emily asked for your question do you
think things will be like this from now
on I think that this franchise has just
given us an unbelievable season of The
Bachelorette oh yeah the bachelor in
paradise premieres next week Monday and
Tuesday on ABC and that they always give
us a different ending that we're blown
away by so cheers to that
cheers to that and cheers to you guys we
love you so much we will be here
recapping bachelor in paradise all
season long Chris Harrison told me this
is the best season of bachelor in
paradise ever we're coming off a cold
and Underwood
great have the best season of VIP ever
Jenn we'll be covering it I will we are
working on exclusives for you and we
will keep you posted on speaking with
Jed's exhale East evens also I'm
interviewing Hannah in New York City I'm
leaving to catch a flight thank you so
we'll have that I love you guys so much
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you